Pat just really fast so Trump's not in
let's say Trump's Trump's not even it's
next election cycle out of everybody
that was up there who do you think would
who would it be close or doctor no I'm
saying would you know you've had so many
Pat's 20 sold me when he told me this 20
I was like I think he was sure changing
yourself but yeah and just from you
seeing it the the speaking the policies
the everything that you heard from
everybody up there who would be your
number one pick to to be the president
of the United States if you had to pick
no Trump trump is out of the picture who
do you pick out of the guys on the stage
everybody that was on stage and we have
to vote today and you have to vote today
mail-in ballots
who do you think who do you feel who do
you feel me and you were there live who
do you thought who who who edged to the
front who'd you think was really bad on
the spot right hey I'm gonna ask you too
Adam oh you two Rob Rob Trump is
out who do you you have to vote we're
voting today I already have my answer
if if today you have to vote there's no
Trump trump is gone to me it's not even
a question it's Vivek okay it's not even
a question that is me now I've said once
or twice that the Republican party of
old white men is not voting for a skinny
little brown kid with a fat with a weird
name so that's a different answer but I
would vote for Viva and give me the one
the one the one thing that sticks out
for you Revolution Vinnie are you
serious are you serious you're joking
what are you doing sleepwalking through
life time to wake up and have a
revolution I love it sick of your
so you so you you are with I think he's
such a stud I think he's got a business
background I think he's sharp I think I
think captivated so here's here's here's
what I would have to say if it's like a
I have to decide today
it's I don't know enough yet to see I
feel like I feel like I need a little
bit more
for me to be able to vote today I don't
think I have enough information on Vivek
to be able to vote today
um
I'll tell you he's more my kind of a guy
than anybody else on the under stage
he's more my kind of guy than anybody on
the yeah when you talk to a lot of
people they're like wow listen he's a
Chachi BT he's this he's Indian he's
Hindu do you trust him you know he was
WF World economic Forum Sorrows all this
other stuff I I want him to get cornered
with all those questions and see how he
answers and when I asked him the
question about vaccine it was
uncomfortable but you know what he said
he says look I was traveling I'm doing
business
I had to take the vaccine but if I had
to do it all over again guess what I
wouldn't have taken a vaccine okay the
angle he took you know what I say to
that cool I respect it you made a
mistake you wouldn't have done it again
I'll take that from you I'm totally cool
with that I can receive that
um when he's getting cornered by Acosta
how he responded when he's being
challenged when he's being pushed around
do I worry on what he's going to do when
he sits across these other guys I don't
think he's a guy that gets intimidated
no I mean he's done business deals with
so many different people I don't yeah he
doesn't look like a guy they can push
him around or be scared he stood up to
Mike Pence when Chris Christie says you
know here's a guy that uh you know he
gave the speech and Barack Obama do we
want another Barack Obama and then Vivek
said yeah why don't you come and give me
a hug just like Barack Obama help them
win so so again look that that really is
that that willingness that he came to
Boom I'm going to give it to you I like
it so for me he's got that part I that
you know with the senses I almost feel
bad with the sentence let me tell you
why I feel about with the sentence I I
feel bad
because you know there's nothing more
annoying
it's very hard to do this what I'm about
to say
when somebody is dying to have a job
but they're just not cut out for it
to have that job
okay or you're you're dying to be us you
know you know the whole saying you can
be anything you want when you grow up
that's a lie
it just is a lie I can't be anything I
want if I want to grow up if I said
since 12 years old I want to be the
freaking Dunk Contest champion in the
NBA did I get 20 inch vertical leap I'm
not winning a dunk contest in a freaking
junior high school with nine foot rims
you know you are the Armenian Dennis
Rodman you're a rebounder yeah hey
sharpen those elbows Bill and beer style
you get in there I I want to be the
greatest coach of all time it's not
gonna happen no I want to be the
greatest compliance officer of all time
okay I want to be think about that yeah
so there is a part that either he has to
calm down in these types of settings and
he needs a to be a little bit more
smiling happy selling the dream likable
all of that stuff and win me over Mike
Pence is running on seeing him as a
father figure and we want him as a
father to go be depressed That's Mike
Pence's brand so he talks like a father
to you and I remember when I was uh
back in the days my father
and that awkward five second pause did
you get 60 seconds you just not a
two-hour podcast yeah so so Pence is
positioning himself to be your father as
a president the Santa's positioning
himself to say you're he's the smartest
guy to be the president most qualified
guy you got Tim Scott a positioning
himself guys everything's gonna be all
right and you know we got okay no
problem
is you know running it as look I want to
roll up my sleeves get to work we're
going to do this like try to catch up
because I'm gonna outwork everybody
we're gonna have a blast another and
he's a sense of humor the day of the
debate you know what he was doing the
morning of the day the debate he he's
playing what was he doing was he in the
morning went on a boat or something like
that or playing basketball just chilling
and then he goes to the hits the stage
at the debate and he's doing a video
with his kid and he says hey honey any
feedback for me before I hit the debate
one of his kids says you know watch out
for Christy you know he's going to come
after you and he posted a video on
you're showing tennis video so he's got
that
the Indian John F Kennedy except he's
the guy that made the money not his
parents and even Obama to make money
this guy made his own money he's a
self-made guy so I would say today it
would be him by the way watch this rock
can you show the picture of trending can
you show the picture of training I sent
you on who was training on the same day
same time you know not this one the
other one keep going one other one one
other one I had one other picture I sent
you uh you don't have that one okay I
have a picture here
I'll try to send this over to you two
people were training on Twitter at the
same time one is vivec 491 000 posts the
other one is Rama Swani 260 16 000 posts
it's the same freaking guy that's how
bad he was trending on uh uh Twitter and
what I told him Rob I just sent this to
you how good he was trending yeah that's
the one how good he was trending but
here's the point here's here's the point
where I told him as well I said listen
ain't nobody running without having to
overcome some kind of a you know uh
skeletons or something they're they're
about to come after the guy yeah like
really oh yeah come after the guy
hardcore especially after last night
they're gonna come after him they're
going to call all his old enemies all
old access all old business partners all
old everything there's going to be
Billboards in around the high school he
went to around the college he went to
saying what dirt do you have on vivec
text us as dirt right
right pictures they're gonna get all the
by the way you know Dylan Dennis guy
that kept posting pictures about Logan's
girl yeah guess what guess who's sending
it to him all of former friends of her
that don't like her that send the
pictures to Dylan and Dylan that's how
you get it like when you target somebody
so I remember when uh uh what was his
name uh from uh Texas the governor
governor governor Greg Abbott not Greg
Abbott prior to that uh Rick Perry you
know
Rob is your mic on or off because it
makes a sound when you're doing that
okay so they would text Governor that
would uh call people in Texas and say
who do you know that hooked up who do
you know not Abbott how do you know
these are good looking guys
there's ways of doing it but yeah that's
a dirty side of politics this is when it
gets dirty yeah sushio yeah so guess
what Vivek is about to go through it oh
it's all it is he's about to go through
it between now and September 27th you
know when it's going to be in Ronald
Reagan Library we're going to see what's
gonna happen there so can we go into the
taco and the Trump thing let's can I
give you the last thing about what Vivek
said I think it was very powerful the
last thing his last things we this is
the reason why vivec captivates people
because he can
just off the hip oh that's why you
hugged Obama all right cool yeah yeah
that's spoken like a true lifelong
politician bang bang he can very quick
with uh the the retorts but then when
it's time for him to State his case he's
direct number one God is real number two
there are two genders number three human
flourishing requires fossil fuels
saying that yep when a country that's
going green a green new deal right
number four reverse racism is racism
number five an open border is no border
very direct number six parents determine
the education of their children number
seven the nuclear family is the greatest
form of governance known to mankind
number eight capitalism lifts people up
from poverty okay number nine there are
three branches of government not for
basically calling out the alphabet soup
out there and the number 10 the U.S
Constitution is the strongest guarantor
of freedom in history very direct very
clear knows what he stands for so vivec
is an absolute Beast great you know by
the way for those who watch them we're
about to launch our next uh Town Hall
we're going to be doing here live the
last one we did was with vivec the place
was jam-packed we couldn't fit anybody
in that place it was like 300 people in
the building uh if you want to be a part
of that the VIP ticket sold out very
quickly everybody got a chance to meet
Vivek and at the Cigar Lounge which was
kind of a great experience audience for
those who attended I can't tell you who
our next person is but if you want to be
the first to buy the tickets lock in
your spot text award podcast to
310-340-1132 once again text award
podcast to
310-340-1132 to be notified because
those people in the text get the first
notification of who's going to be on the
podcast so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]